Ein tropisches Naturparadies
im Indischen Ozean,
das sind die Seychellen.
Hier gibt es viele Mantarochen,
denn hier finden sie
nahezu perfekte Bedingungen.
Wie bestellt!
Wir haben gerade ungefähr
drei, vier, fünf Mantas vor uns.
Da ist gerade einer.
Jetzt schauen wir sie uns kurz an.
Es ist immer wunderschön,
Mantas zu sehen.
Neben den Hai-Beobachtungen gehört
es sicher zu den exklusiven Dingen,
die man hier machen kann.
Es ist wunderschön, wie sie mit
ihren Flügeln schwimmen, so elegant.
Das ist wirklich schön.
Ornella Weideli ist Biologin
und schreibt ihre Doktorarbeit
über Junghaie.
Sie wird von der Schweizer Stiftung
Save Our Seas unterstützt,
die hier auch
ein Manta-Projekt betreibt.
Michael Scholl
ist der Direktor der Stiftung.
Zusammen tauchen sie ab,
um zu prüfen, wie es
um die anmutigen Meerestiere steht.
* Sanfte, entspannte Klänge *
Ornella macht Belly Shots,
Fotos vom Bauch der Tiere.
Denn jedes Exemplar
hat eine individuelle Bauchzeichnung.
Die Bilder helfen der Wiedererkennung
und sind wichtig,
um die Wanderung der Tiere
nachzuvollziehen.
Die Tiere sind imposant
und die Spannweite der Brustflossen
kann bis zu 7 m betragen.
Die friedlichen Giganten
ernähren sich v.a. von Plankton,
das sie in Küstennähe,
bei Fels- und Korallenriffen finden.
* Meeresrauschen *
Super!
Wir haben versucht,
möglichst viele Belly Shots,
also Bauchfotos zu machen.
Es ist immer das Beste,
wenn man unter den Mantas ist,
sie über einen durchschwimmen
und das Licht langsam tiefer kommt.
Unter Wasser sind sie so elegant!
Sie tanzen einfach so ...
... um dich herum,
das ist wunderschön.
Die habe ich mitgenommen, weil ...
Weil du durstig bist.
- Nein nicht ganz.
Ich schwamm auf der Oberfläche,
der Manta ist gekommen,
und die Flasche war so vor ihm.
Würde die in seinem Mund landen,
wäre das nicht so gut.
Also habe ich sie mitgenommen.
Dass in den Ozeanen weltweit
86 Mio. t Plastik schwimmen,
ist für die Forscherin alarmierend.
Denn für die Meeresbewohner kann es
zu einer tödlichen Mahlzeit werden.
In Indonesien ist Umweltlehrer Jonas
Müller unterwegs zur Insel Arborek.
Hier unten!
* Entspannte Gitarrenmusik
begleitet von ruhigem Pfeifen *
Dort ist soeben
einer rausgesprungen.
Auch hier, fast 9'000 km
von den Seychellen entfernt,
sorgen Mantarochen
für grosse Begeisterung.
Doch eigentlich hat Jonas heute
etwas ganz anderes im Sinn:
Ich habe über ein Jahr lang
auf dieser kleinen Insel gelebt.
Ich wurde hier
von einer Familie adoptiert
und werde heute also
meine Adoptiveltern besuchen.
Der gebürtige Glarner Jonas Müller
lebt seit 2015 in Raja Ampat.
Erst arbeitete er für eine NGO
und lernte Indonesisch.
Dann eröffnete er
seine eigene Umweltschule.
Eine einheimische Familie
schloss ihn ins Herz und half,
dass er bald
Teil der Dorfgemeinschaft wurde.
Mal schauen, ob jemand zu Hause ist.
Hey!
Emma Mambraku Di Mara begrüsst Jonas.
Er hat sich an der Hand verletzt.
Oh, er ist schwer geworden.
Schau, hier hat er sich wehgetan.
- Tut das weh?
Er hat sich am Feuerzeug verbrannt.
Das ist der kleine Jonas
von Arborek.
He?
Tii!
- Gut.
Dass das jüngste Kind der Familie
nach ihm benannt wurde,
berührt Jonas.
Willst du runter?
Ja.
Er ist für mich schon
wie ein eigenes Kind.
Wohin gehst du?
Hier ist noch ein Foto
meiner Mama aus der Schweiz,
als Jonas noch kleiner war, zusammen
mit der Mama von Raja Ampat.
Fang den Ball!
Eins, zwei, drei.
* Er spricht indonesisch. *
Irgendwann sagten sie mir:
"Komm doch hierher etwas trinken!"
Irgendwann hiess es:
"Iss doch hier zu Mittag!"
Dann: "Iss doch hier zu Abend!"
Und irgendwann hiess es:
"Schlaf doch gleich hier!"
So quasi: "Hol deine Sachen
und wohne mit uns!"
Und irgendwann hiess es:
"Sag mir Mama und sag mir Papa!"
So lief es Schritt für Schritt.
Hier ist Jonas jederzeit willkommen.
Es ist schön,
Jonas als weiteren Sohn zu haben.
Er hilft mir,
wenn ich etwas brauche.
Und ich schaue zu ihm.
Für mich sind es absolut
Mama und Papa hier in Raja Ampat.
Ich glaube,
das kann man wirklich so sagen.
Sie kann mit mir schimpfen
wie meine Mama in der Schweiz auch.
Meine Mama in der Schweiz ist froh,
dass das hier auch jemand tut.
Vorhin hat sie mit mir geschimpft,
weil ich wieder verletzt bin.
Die Verletzung
wird bald wieder ein Thema sein.
Denn Jonas'
leibliche Eltern aus der Schweiz
sind auf dem Weg hierher.
Das Engadin
liegt unter einer Schneedecke.
Beim Silsersee liegt die Temperatur
bei kühlen 2 °C.
Das perfekte Wetter zum Eistauchen,
finden Adelrich Uhr
und seine Tochter.
Ich ging schon oft Eistauchen,
früher schon,
und meine Tochter Tanja
macht jetzt einen Eistauchkurs.
Heute gehen wir zum ersten Mal
zusammen unter die Eisdecke.
Der erfahrene Tauchinstruktor weiss:
Eistauchen macht man nur in der
Gruppe, alleine wäre es zu riskant.
Es wird sonst zu kalt,
wenn wir unter dem Eis sind.
Adelrich, den alle nur Agi nennen,
liebt alle Tauchsportarten.
Darum kennt er sämtliche Tricks,
um der klirrenden Kälte zu trotzen.
Jetzt haben wir hier
einen Trockentauchanzug.
Da dringt absolut kein Wasser
an den Körper.
Mit einem solchen Anzug kann man
auch etwa doppelt so lange tauchen,
da er
einen besseren Kälteschutz bietet.
Dann habe ich noch solche Pads
in den Schuhen.
Das sind spezielle Kleber,
die man kaufen kann
und die 5 Std. lang Wärme abgeben.
Und dann kommen noch solche Socken,
die auch
einen besseren Kälteschutz bieten.
Das Wasser ist doch ca. 2 °C kalt,
und man verbringt ca. 20 Min. darin.
Mit der Zeit
wird es schon ziemlich kalt.
Tauchen im Eiswasser -
für die meisten
eine abschreckende Vorstellung.
Tochter Tanja liebt warme Gewässer.
Die Wärmepads helfen ihr, sich an
die Welt der Kalttaucher zu gewöhnen.
Gut, danke!
Jetzt kommt der unangenehme Teil.
Die Haare sein lassen?
- Nein, da kommt ja Wasser rein.
Ich hätte gerne einen Männerschnitt.
- Das glaube ich.
Wenn diese Härchen hier drin sind,
dringt oben Wasser ein
und verbreitet sich. Dann geht man
schnell wieder aus dem Wasser.
Das ist eine einmalige Gelegenheit.
Es ist nicht so einfach ...
Man kann nicht einfach ein Loch
in einen See bohren und abtauchen,
sondern man braucht
Sicherheitsleute,
Leute, die an der Leine sind,
an der Buddyleine,
das sehen wir alles
unten beim Loch.
* Ruhige Harmonikamusik *
* Entspannte Gitarrenmusik
begleitet von ruhigem Pfeifen *
In Raja Ampat bei Westpapua
hat Jonas seine Eltern abgeholt.
Die Glarner Walti und Susi Müller
waren fast drei Tage unterwegs,
um ihren Sohn zu besuchen.
Ihr seid ja beim letzten Mal
nicht ganz um die Insel gefahren.
Hinten durch sind wir ...
Ihr seid auf die andere Seite
gefahren und habt dort gewendet.
Als ihr die vielen Delfine
gesehen habt. - Genau.
Dann kommen sie in Sawinggrai an,
ein kleines Dorf, das seit zwei
Jahren die Wahlheimat von Jonas ist.
Ich habe keine Badeschuhe.
Primarlehrer Walti entdeckt Iskander,
der herumlungert.
Immer noch nicht in der Schule.
Vielleicht ist der Lehrer krank.
* Ein Hahn kräht. *
Hi!
- Hi!
Iskander!
- Good.
Ja? Hoi!
Scuola? No? Good?
- Yes, Scola.
Maybe.
School
- All is okay?
Die Eltern freuen sich auf
die gemeinsamen Tage mit ihrem Sohn.
Während des Jahres bekommen sie den
28-Jährigen nur per Skype zu Gesicht.
Es ist natürlich super,
wenn sie hierherkommen.
Ich habe so nicht das Gefühl,
ich müsse in die Schweiz,
um sie zu sehen.
Es ist natürlich schön, dass sie
mich schon zum dritten Mal besuchen
und dass wir diese Schönheit hier
miteinander teilen können.
Wenn ich Glück habe, ist noch
eine gute Flasche Wein im Koffer.
Das ist ganz klar.
Er hat Raclette bestellt.
Das ist sicher gut -
wie auch Schokolade.
Und es ist natürlich
jedes Mal ein Highlight,
wenn wir zusammen
ein Gläschen Wein trinken können.
Ich habe auch
einen guten Rotwein mitgebracht.
Ein Wunder,
dass sie die Reise überlebt haben.
Als wir das erste Mal da waren,
hatte wir jede Nacht Ratten hier.
Ich hatte einen Notvorrat dabei,
Farmerstengel und so,
und das haben nicht wir,
sondern die Ratten
in der Nacht gegessen.
Deshalb habe ich jetzt alles schön
in eine Keksdose verpackt.
Da passiert sicher nichts.
Die Riegel werden also
wirklich wir essen.
Super!
Eines der seltenen Baumkängurus
äugt zwischen den Blättern hervor.
Fast scheint es,
als ob es den Besuch aus Näfels
willkommen heissen wolle.
Mahe ist die Hauptinsel der
Seychellen mitten im Indischen Ozean.
Haiforscherin Ornella Weideli
streift mit dem Schweizer
Wissenschafter Karl Fleischmann
und seinem Kollegen
durch einen Mangrovenwald.
In diesem geschützten Gebiet
gibt es zahlreiche Junghaie.
Es ist Futterplatz und Kinderstube
für junge Haie und andere Fische.
Babyhaie wachsen hier auf
und finden Futter.
Welche Haie leben hier?
Zitronenhaie? - Zitronenhaie.
Bullenhaie?
- Möglich, ja.
Schon gesehen?
Nein,
sie zeigen sich selten tagsüber.
Es ist jetzt sehr trüb.
Ist es normalerweise klarer?
Ja, viel klarer.
Terence Vel engagiert sich
seit vielen Jahren für dieses Gebiet.
Denn Mangroven sind ein wichtiger
Küstenschutz für Mensch und Tier.
Aber sie wurden jahrelang
rücksichtslos gerodet.
Nun koordiniert Vel
die Wiederaufforstung dieser Wälder.
Als ich zum ersten Mal
einen Junghai gesehen habe,
habe ich auch zum ersten Mal
Mangroven gesehen.
Das lernt man zusammen.
Das war auf den Bahamas.
Dort spielen Mangroven eine sehr
wichtige Rolle - wie auch hier.
Leider wurde auch dort
viel zerstört,
weil sie an vielen Orten
Mücken anziehen
und der Normalo-Tourist
Mücken nicht mag.
Das ist überall ein Problem.
Durch die Überbauung
von Küstenstreifen
wurden diese wichtigen Ökosysteme
und Klimagasspeicher zerstört.
Weltweit.
Nun soll in Mahe
die Wiederaufforstung
den Tieren
ihren Lebensraum zurückgeben.
Der Regen wird hier
von Jahr zu Jahr heftiger.
Davon gehen allgemein akzeptierte
Klimamodelle aus.
Dennoch gibt es weniger Frischwasser.
Wegen der globalen Klimaerwärmung
verdunsten Pflanzen mehr Wasser
und haben einen höheren Wasserbedarf.
Auch der Tourismus
schadet der Umwelt.
Ornella ist konsequenterweise
Vegetarierin.
Ich habe mir früher gesagt,
ich möchte mich lokal ernähren,
also lokalen Fisch essen.
Aber dann stellt sich die Frage:
"Wie wurde er gefischt?"
Es reicht nicht, wenn ich weiss,
dass er von hier ist.
Wenn viele Touristen hier sind,
wird bestimmt viel Fisch konsumiert,
und in diesen Fischfangmethoden
ist der Hai sehr oft ein Beifang,
was ein riesengrosses Problem ist.
Wir sind hier an einem Ort
mit High-end-tourism.
Da gibt es natürlich
einen riesigen Wasserbedarf.
Nur schon mit der Wäsche, das
denke ich jedes Mal in den Hotels.
Ich wollte heute
auf einen Zettel schreiben,
sie sollen meine Tücher
bitte nicht waschen.
Man braucht enorm viele Ressourcen,
um diesen High-End-Tourismus
überhaupt befriedigen zu können.
- Ja, ja.
Schmeckt es?
- Mhm!
Was ist es? Gemüse?
- Ich bin hungrig.
Der Wald macht hungrig.
- Ja.
Im indonesischen Dorf Sawinggrai
soll für die gemeinsame Mahlzeit
alles perfekt sein.
Jonas und seine Eltern
haben sich viel zu erzählen.
Auf dem Speiseplan
stehen Reis, Nudeln, Gemüse und Ei.
Der Wein wird für später aufgehoben.
Nein,
den kannst du so nicht trinken.
Das ist schade, er ist zu warm.
Die Eltern unterstützen Jonas
und sein Umweltprojekt,
auch wenn er dafür seine Karriere
als Betriebsökonom in der Schweiz
aufgegeben hat.
Aus Erfahrung wissen sie:
Wenn ihr Sohn sich etwas in den Kopf
gesetzt hat, hält ihn nichts auf.
Du warst natürlich von klein auf
einer, der immer genau wusste,
was zu tun ist.
Als Zweijähriger wollte er
ganz alleine mit dem Postauto
ins Seedammcenter fahren,
um Sugus zu kaufen.
Das sagtest du uns.
- Ich wäre auch gegangen.
Guten Appetit.
- Guten Appetit.
Wie die Adoptivmama
macht sich auch seine Mutter Sorgen
wegen der Verletzung an Jonas' Fuss.
Er schaut nicht immer
so gut zu sich.
Das sieht man an all den Blessuren,
die er hat.
Die habe ich zu Hause
genau gleich wie hier.
Wir erfahren einfach jeweils nichts.
Doch, du schon, aber Mama nicht.
Also immer erst viel später.
- Wenn es wieder gut ist.
Wie damals, als Jonas von einem
Blauringoktopus gebissen wurde
und in Lebensgefahr war.
In der Schweiz wurde ihm später
eine Zehe amputiert.
Mama hat von Anfang an,
als sie es gehört und das erste Foto
gesehen hat, gesagt:
"Jonas, komm doch heim,
um das auszukurieren."
Und er sagte: "Nein, nein, Mum,
das wird schon wieder."
Wenn ich jedes Mal heimkommen würde,
wenn du es mir vorschlägst,
wäre ich alle zwei Monate zu Hause.
Nein, nein, so schlimm ist es nicht.
Aber da war es wirklich nötig.
Darum gibt er immer erst Bescheid,
wenn es auskuriert ist.
Die Eltern haben das
unkonventionelle Leben ihres Sohnes
schon lange akzeptiert.
So, wie es jetzt ist,
stimmt das wohl für alle.
Ja, wer weiss,
wenn du dann pensioniert bist.
Dann bleibst du vielleicht
länger als zwei Wochen hier.
Das ist wahrscheinlich,
das ist schon ziemlich sicher.
Walti Müller will in zwei Jahren
in Pension gehen.
Dann kann Jonas mit
tatkräftiger Unterstützung rechnen.
* Ruhige Gitarrenklänge *
Auf Mahe,
der Hauptinsel der Seychellen,
begleitet Ornella Weideli
den ehemaligen ETH-Dozenten
Karl Fleischmann.
Er koordiniert für die lokale
Universität diverse Waldprojekte.
Schau mal!
Alles überwuchert.
Das möchte ich dir wirklich
noch kurz zeigen.
Sie haben es zuerst für die
Landwirtschaft hineingebracht.
Als Viehfutter.
Eine vermutlich
eingeschleppte Schlingpflanze
trägt zur Wasserknappheit
auf der Insel bei,
denn ihr Wasserbedarf ist sehr hoch.
- Es ist wahnsinnig.
Und es ist unglaublich,
dass eine solche Pflanze zu einem
landschaftsprägenden Element wird.
Auf den Seychellen hatten wir
in den letzten zehn Jahren
eigentlich mehr Regen,
mehr Niederschläge.
Und trotzdem
ist die Trinkwassermenge geringer.
Sind sich die Leute dessen bewusst?
- Es ist schwierig.
Die Leute leben damit,
und für sehr viele Leute,
die wenig über den Wald wissen,
ist das einfach schön grün.
- Es sieht ja wunderschön aus.
Aber dort oben sieht man es bereits:
Das sind alles endemische Pflanzen.
Endemisch heisst,
sie wachsen nur hier.
Stellt man auch fest,
dass die Pflanzen absterben?
Sie sterben ab.
Das kann man auch verfolgen?
- Ja, ja.
Wollen wir weitergehen?
- Gerne.
Ja, der Mensch.
Karl Fleischmann
bekämpft die Eindringlinge.
Mit Studenten tauscht er
eingeschleppte Pflanzen
gegen einheimische aus.
Man merkt jetzt,
wie dunkel es hier ist.
Das ist genau das,
was der Wald braucht.
Je dunkler der Wald ist,
desto weniger können
invasive Pflanzen Fuss fassen.
Dieses Beispiel ist wunderschön.
Es ist eigentlich
eine Mahagoni-Plantage
und man sieht sehr schön,
wie der Wald wieder übernimmt,
der natürliche, native Wald -
mit den endemischen Palmen, die es
nur hier auf den Seychellen gibt.
Karl Fleischmann und Ornella Weideli,
zwei Schweizer,
die sich mit viel Herzblut
für die Wasserwelten
der Seychellen engagieren.
Beide auf ihre Weise.
* Ruhige Gitarrenklänge,
Plätschern der Regentropfen *
Von den Tropen zum Polarkreis.
Hier, im Osten Grönlands,
macht sich eine Expedition
zum Aufbruch bereit.
In Tasiilaq holt ein Schneescooter
den Schweizer Multimediajournalisten
Robert Hansen ab.
Die Temperatur
liegt um den Nullpunkt.
Für Robert ist das T-Shirt-Wetter.
Auf dem zugefrorenen Fjord
will er in eisige Gewässer abtauchen.
Kalttauchen ist eine grosse Passion
des 52-Jährigen.
Doch vor dem eisigen Abenteuer
wartet viel Arbeit auf ihn.
Schneeschaufeln.
Eigentlich völlig bescheuert,
weil es ziemlich viel Schnee hat.
Das mache ich zu Hause
schon nicht gerne,
und jetzt mache ich es
in den Ferien schon wieder.
* Angestrengtes Stöhnen *
Ich frage mich im Moment auch,
weshalb ich an einem
solch absurden Ort tauchen möchte.
Der Reiz liegt natürlich
10 m weiter unten.
Aber zuerst muss man mal
dort hinkommen,
und das geht nur, wenn man
Eis und Schnee wegschaufelt.
So, da kommt die Ablösung.
Aber auch die Kollegen
tun sich schwer
mit der fast meterdicken Eisdecke.
Das Problem ist,
überhaupt ein Loch graben zu können.
Wir sägen kleinere Stücke
und versuchen, die zu entfernen,
damit wir überhaupt ein Loch haben,
durch das wir ins Wasser reinkommen.
Dass das so dick ist,
hätte niemand gedacht.
* Spannende, trommelähnliche Klänge *
Raja Ampat ist ein weltweit bekannter
Hotspot für Taucher und Schnorchler.
Hast du eine Maske?
- Ja.
Du hingegen brauchst eine.
Ich lasse meine Brille hier.
Jonas will seinen Eltern
die Schönheit der indonesischen
Unterwasserwelt zeigen.
Perfekt.
Ich suche das Wasser
sonst gar nicht.
Hier bei Jonas
ist es eine grosse Ausnahme -
diese Unterwasserwelt,
was es hier alles zu sehen gibt.
Das ist unglaublich!
Da muss man fast schnorcheln.
In der Schweiz zieht es
die Bibliothekarin in die Berge.
Die sind ihr Element.
* Die Kinder
ahmen Motorengeräusche nach. *
Machen wir mit den Jungs ein Rennen.
Come!
Alle Jungs zu mir!
Der Lehrer bricht wieder durch.
* Ein Kind schreit etwas
auf Indonesisch. *
Du schaffst es ja wohl,
die Kinder zu organisieren.
Pfeife mal, dann kommen sie schon.
* Lauter Pfiff *
Come!
* Die Kinder rufen etwas
auf Indonesisch. *
Wartet hier!
Eins, zwei, zweieinhalb, drei!
* Lachen *
Gratuliere!
Also, schnorcheln?
- Schnorcheln, es wird heiss.
Ich bin froh,
dass es eine Treppe hat.
Dann muss ich nicht springen, Jonas.
Wobei diese Höhe noch ginge.
Da springst du jetzt rein, Mutter!
- Ja, sicher.
Sonst nehme ich dich auf die Arme
und springe mit dir.
Melando fliegt
auch gleich ins Wasser,
er weiss es nur noch nicht.
Schau, er geht von alleine.
Eins, zwei, drei.
Die Maske festhalten!
Raja Ampat ist eines der arten-
reichsten Meeresgebiete der Erde.
Und nicht zuletzt darum
ein Paradies für Mensch und Fisch.
Die Stille
der weiten Landschaft Grönlands
wird einzig von einem
monotonen Geräusch durchbrochen.
Wir sind seit 3 Std. dran und haben
noch kein brauchbares Loch.
Ich versuche an einem anderen Ort
ein Loch zu bohren, um zu sehen,
wie dick das Eis hier ist.
Dafür, dass wir dann
30 Min. lang tauchen können,
weil es danach viel zu kalt ist,
sind Aufwand und Ertrag ...
Na ja.
Wir werden es sehen.
Ja, hier ist es genauso dick.
Ich glaube,
wir müssen an einen anderen Ort.
Bis wir hier
ein brauchbares Loch haben ...
... ist Frühling.
Anders als in Grönland wird auf dem
Silsersee nicht lange gefackelt.
Agi Uhr und seine Tochter staunen,
wie routiniert der langjährige
Polizeitaucher Urs Grigoli
das Einstiegsloch öffnet.
Ein wenig dagegen stossen.
Wo sind die zwei Schaufeln?
Da hinten.
Siehst du?
Die kannst du runterlassen.
Das ist der Grund.
- So sehen wir es nachher unten?
So haben wir es danach unten?
- Ja.
Das ist ein Sandwicheis.
Es sind
verschiedene Schichten zusammen.
Alles in allem gibt es doch
eine fast 40 cm dicke Eisschicht,
das ist nicht sehr viel.
Wir hatten schon
Schwarzeisschichten von 70 cm.
Das gibt es also auch.
* Surren der Druckluftflasche *
Gut!
Wie viele Bar hast du?
Ich habe 200.
Agi und Tanja machen den Buddy-Check.
180.
Tanja hatte den Theorieteil
schon vorher,
nun folgt der praktische Teil.
Es ist eigentlich
kein grosser Unterschied,
ob wir einen Eisdeckel haben
oder nicht.
Der einzige Unterschied ist, dass
wir nicht bis auf den Grund gehen,
sondern unter der Eisdecke bleiben,
denn die Faszination ist dort.
Dort sehen wir die Strukturen,
wie das Eis gewachsen ist.
Jeder Taucher muss sich anseilen.
So findet er zurück zum Einstiegsloch
und kann Zeichen geben,
wenn er in Schwierigkeiten gerät.
Ganz der Vater
taucht Tanja mutig als Erste ab.
Es ist ihre Premiere,
noch weiss sie nicht,
was sie unter dem Eis erwartet.
Einmal ziehen: Du gibst mir.
Zweimal ziehen: Okay.
Dreimal ziehen:
Du ziehst uns alle raus.
Nein!
Einmal ziehen: Ich gebe.
Zweimal ziehen:
Ich nehme Leine zurück.
Und dreimal und mehrmals ziehen
ist ein Notzeichen,
und dann kommt der Standby-Taucher.
- Okay.
* Entspannte,
perlende Gitarrenklänge *
Wir sind zurück in der magischen
Unterwasserwelt von Raja Ampat.
Es ist ein Ort mit der
weltweit grössten Biodiversität.
Jonas Müller will mithelfen,
diese zu erhalten.
Susi Müller hat
ihre anfängliche Skepsis überwunden
und wird mit einem
einzigartigen Einblick belohnt.
Bis zum Haus schnorcheln.
Hast du etwas gesehen?
Hey, eine Superschildkröte.
- Ja.
Da draussen war ziemlich viel los.
- Ja, ja.
Wunderschön.
Hast du die grosse Makrele
auch gesehen?
Jene, die du verjagt hast, ja.
Fantastisch, was es alles gibt.
Jetzt haben wir eine wunderschöne
Schildkröte gesehen.
Was ich gar nicht mochte, war,
als wir übers Gras geschwommen sind.
Nicht?
- Das Gras am Bauch. Brr!
Ja gut,
du mit deinem dicken Bauch.
Die Unterwasserbilder
werden die Eltern
wohl auch zu Hause in Näfels
noch lange begleiten.
* Monotone, entspannte Klänge *
Auf dem zugefrorenen Fjord
im Osten Grönlands
wird den Eistauchern
nichts geschenkt.
Noch immer ist Handarbeit angesagt.
Salzwasser würde eine Motorsäge
sofort zerstören.
Wie lange sägen wir schon?
Etwa 4, 5 Std.
Ich hatte mir schon vorgestellt,
dass es anstrengend würde.
Das kann einem auch auf einem
Schweizer Bergsee passieren.
Aber das ist schon extrem,
wenn man erst noch 80, 90 cm
dickes Eis durchsägen muss.
Das schon, ja.
(Angestrengt) Ja!
Endlich gerät das tonnenschwere Eis
in Bewegung.
Das schaffst du alleine.
Willst du den hier?
- Ja, voll!
Wir haben's.
- Ab ins Wasser!
Es ist vollbracht!
Der Eingang zur eisigen
Unterwasserwelt ist offen.
* Entspannte Musik, Röcheln *
Eisstrukturen
mit eingeschlossenen Luftblasen.
So sieht die Welt unter Wasser
im Oberengadiner Silsersee aus.
Das Licht,
das durch das Eis schimmert,
verleiht der Szenerie
etwas Entrücktes.
Dann stellt Agi
die Eiswelt auf den Kopf.
Was einfach aussieht,
kann nur ein geübter Taucher.
Er wird dann
irgendwann mal zurückkommen,
weil er keine Leine mehr kriegt.
Jetzt machen sie sowieso Patchwork
mit der Leine, stelle ich fest.
Patchwork mit der Leine -
doch auch in dieser
verfahrenen Situation
bewahrt der erfahrene Taucher Ruhe.
Vater und Tochter haben
den ersten gemeinsamen Eistauchgang
unbeschadet überstanden.
Es war super! Mega schön.
Herrlich, herrlich!
Wie immer beim Eistauchen.
Wunderschön!
Wir sind ungefähr 30 m lang
unter der Eisfläche
in Richtung See geschwommen.
Wir sahen dort die Fischer,
wollten ihnen einen Fisch stehlen,
aber wir sahen selber keinen.
Nein, es war herrlich, nicht wahr?
Ja, es war sehr schön,
so der Eisfläche entlang.
V.a. mit der Luft
sah es sehr toll aus.
Und auch die Temperatur ...
Gut angezogen, guter Wärmeschutz,
also wir haben nicht gefroren.
Also ich zumindest nicht.
Der Vaterstolz ist Agi anzumerken.
Es war wahnsinnig: Sie zeigte
keine Angst, sie atmete ruhig,
der Lungenautomat kann nicht
vereisen, wenn man so ruhig atmet,
er kann nicht abblasen.
Ich bin sehr stolz auf meine Toch-
ter, dass das so gut geklappt hat.
Du hast ihn im Auto vergessen,
jetzt ist es Eistee.
Jetzt machen wir noch
die Diplomübergabe.
Prost -
auf den erfolgreichen Eistauchgang.
Prost!
Tanja, gratuliere dir herzlich zum
Diplom, zum bestandenen Eistauchen.
Hier habe ich noch
ein Diplom für dich. - Danke.
Ich weiss noch nicht,
ob ich es einrahme und aufhänge.
Ich habe jetzt so viele Diplome.
Aber, ja ...
Ich werde es sicher
zu Hause aufstellen.
Lochen und in den Ordner.
- In den Ordner.
Hier verlassen wir Agi und Tanja.
Dass er seine Leidenschaft
für Wasserwelten
an seine Tochter weitergeben konnte,
ist für Agi eine grosse Genugtuung.
Nach stundenlangem Eissägen
kann Robert Hansen endlich
in arktische Gewässer abtauchen.
Schön warm, schön warm eingepackt,
jetzt kann es losgehen.
Über Wasser ist es 0 °C,
unter Wasser -3 °C.
Selbst für Hartgesottene
ist das eine Herausforderung.
* Sphärische Klänge *
Sonnenstrahlen
dringen durch das Eisloch.
Jetzt, am Ende des Winters,
ist die Sicht besonders gut.
Sie ist bis zu 40 m weit.
Robert Hansen scheint entrückt
in dieser ganz eigenen Welt.
Mit seiner Kamera fotografiert er
das Leben unter Wasser:
bunte Riffe und kleine Garnelen.
Bunte Anemonen, die im Licht
der Tauchlampen erstrahlen.
Einen gar nicht scheuen
Skorpionfisch ...
... und blütenartige Schnecken
gibt es zu entdecken.
* Sphärische Klänge, Blubbern *
Für Robert heben sich Zeit und Raum
hier unten auf.
Doch nach 1 Std. zwingt
die Kälte Robert zum Auftauchen.
Traumhaft schön!
Eine sehr spannende Steilwand, bei
der man stundelang zuschauen könnte.
Voller Anemonen und Skorpionfische.
Ah!
Die ersten 40 Min. lief es super.
Am Ende kriegte ich merkwürdiger-
weise kalte Oberschenkel.
Den Zehen geht es relativ gut,
die Finger sind langsam etwas
eingefroren, aber es ist aushaltbar.
Es ist schon am Limit, ja.
Boah!
Diese Hand ist eingefroren,
dieser geht es super.
Mein Mund ist eingefroren,
aber es macht nichts, wenn ich
nicht so viel sprechen kann.
In der letzten Folge
von "Wasserwelten"
erlebt Robert
sein ganz persönliches Highlight.
Ja, das ist
ein Tauchgang für die Ewigkeit.
Jonas Müller
zeigt seinen Schülern
die wunderbare Welt der Mantas.
Sie sagen zumindest,
sie hätten keine Angst.
Und auf den Seychellen
hilft Ornella Weideli mit,
Wasserschildkröten zu schützen.